(playful music)
- [Narrator] This is the
Chick-fil-A chicken sandwich,
which according to
multiple industry surveys
is America's favorite fast food.
Visit a Chick-fil-A anywhere
in the United States
and you're likely to see
a long line of customers,
patiently waiting to order
the restaurant's flagship menu item.
- There you guys go.
- Thank you so much.
- My pleasure.
Y'all have a great rest of your day.
- Thank you.
- My pleasure.
- [Narrator] In part thanks
to its famous chicken,
today Chick-fil-A is the third
largest US restaurant chain
by domestic sales.
- We're still seeing a tremendous
growth in our business.
So far this year, we're up about 20%.
- [Narrator] So how did
this private Atlanta-based
fast food chain become one
of the most popular
restaurants in America?
This is "The Economics of Chick-fil-A."
(upbeat music)
Chick-fil-A has long had a
unique approach to business
that the company credits with its success.
From the beginning, Chick-fil-A's business
was built on a recipe.
After testing hundreds of methods,
restaurateur Truett Cathy
developed a faster way
to cook boneless chicken
using a pressure cooker and peanut oil.
- It's perfect and so we've
kept that locked away in a vault
and we'll continue to
use that same recipe.
- None of the employees have access to it,
so it is still shrouded
in a lot of mystery.
There are recipe sites where
you can try to recreate it
but they have never put it out officially.
- [Narrator] The original chicken sandwich
is the same today as in 1967.
A breaded breast of chicken,
two pickles, both placed
on a buttered toasted bun.
♪ Hey, Chick-fil-A today ♪
♪ Chick-fil-A ♪
♪ The boneless breasted
chicken we're famous for ♪
- [Heather] Chick-fil-A
has long taken pride
for its commitment to
selling high-quality product.
- [Narrator] In fact, Chick-fil-A's name
is a take on chicken filet
with a capital A at the end
symbolizing top-quality.
While other fast food chains tend
to expand their menu offerings over time
to attract new customers,
Chick-fil-A's business model
has always been to maintain a small menu,
focused on chicken sandwiches.
- They like to say it's simple.
So they want to keep customers knowing
what's on that menu
to be able to easily
decipher what they want.
- We think about the way
that we serve guests.
That consistency is really important,
that we get hot sandwiches,
and cold salads,
and just tasty products.
- [Narrator] Customers seem to agree.
Since its creation in 2015,
the American Customer Satisfaction Index
has been dominated by Chick-fil-A.
- Chick-fil-A often rates very high.
Even though the service in
the drive-thru can be slower,
people are very happy with the quality
and the service they get in general.
- [Narrator] Today, many
Chick-fil-A restaurants
use a practice known as upstream ordering
where an associate will
take a customer's order
while they're still waiting in line.
- This started before the pandemic
but has really proved very important
to the pandemic when they
closed their dining rooms,
which really meant the drive-thru
is the major channel of sales.
So if you go to a Chick-fil-A now,
in many locations, you
will see workers out
in the drive-thru with tablets.
And so instead of speaking
into a speaker box
and kind of mumbling your order
and it maybe getting screwed up,
you're telling this person
directly next to your car
what you want.
- [Narrator] To ensure that quality
in every one of its location,
Chick-fil-A uses a
different franchise model
than most other fast food chains.
Unlike most chains where
the franchisee covers most
of the costs of opening the restaurant,
Chick-fil-A owns every
one of its locations.
The company also selects the locations,
and builds the restaurants.
- We really think that
that's a key differentiator
in the way that we operate.
We're not looking for a financial investor
or people that wanna buy a big market
and open a bunch of stores.
- [Narrator] Chick-fil-A
states on their website,
"Franchising is not an opportunity
for passive financial investment,
working from the sidelines,
or adding to a portfolio
of business ventures."
Franchisees are called operators,
and each operator is hand
picked by Chick-fil-A
after a rigorous interview process.
- Chick-fil-A likes to
say it's about like going
to Harvard MBA.
It can take anywhere from
12 months, 24 months.
So you really have to want to do this,
and be willing to go through
the initial paperwork
but then extensive interviews.
- [Narrator] Out of the
more than 8,000 applicants
Chick-fil-A receives annually,
the company only selects about
130 new operators a year.
That's an acceptance
rate lower than Stanford.
- One of the skills
that we really look for
is somebody that's really
good at developing people.
A lot of the stores
have over 100 employees.
They've gotta be really, really good
at pouring in and developing people
in teams and leadership teams.
- [Narrator] If selected,
Chick-fil-A franchisees
needs only an initial
investment of $10,000,
which covers the franchise fee
to become an operator.
That's much lower than the startup costs
for a McDonald's franchise,
which requires a $45,000 franchise fee,
as well as 1.3 to $2.3 million
of additional investment.
- If they have 10 or 15 locations,
it's hard to have that market presence
and to really know their team members
and the communities that we serve.
And we've got a lot of
interest to become operators,
and feel like that model
is gonna be really important.
It's what's gotten us to where we are.
- [Narrator] Chick-fil-A
credits this hands-on approach
with the success of its restaurants,
which on average, make far
more off of each location
than their competition.
For years, Chick-fil-A's footprint
was mostly in the southeast,
but today, it can be
found across the country.
- They have about 2,600 restaurants
throughout the country.
They're also located in Canada
and they're opening in Puerto Rico.
- We're opening about 100
stores a year right now
and we've got a lot of
growth potential here
just domestically in United States
but we're also looking
at international as well.
- [Narrator] Since 2007,
Chick-fil-A's nearly doubled
its restaurant count to 2,598.
- Compared to a lot of other chains,
that's still slow.
Like a Chipotle is opening
200 restaurants a year.
- [Narrator] No matter
which Chick-fil-A location
you eat at,
the company says its values are reflected
in its day-to-day operations.
- It is a very close culture.
They're also invested in its values,
which they do say are based
on Judeo-Christian values,
which you don't have to be
a Christian to work there
but they do take some
of these basic values
of humility and generosity,
and if you wanna go to a prayer
service while you're there,
you certainly can.
- [Narrator] From its inception,
founder Truett Cathy's Christian
faith played a major role
in the company's business strategy.
It's why Chick-fil-As
are never open on Sunday,
not just so workers can attend church
but also so they can rest in general.
- We feel like we make up for the sales
in the Monday through Saturday,
and that anticipation of I
can't get Chick-fil-A today,
so I wanna make sure to go
first thing Monday morning.
- [Narrator] It's also
the reason the company
has never gone public.
- I don't think we'll ever,
actually, I know we'll never go public.
And there's not a real
benefit for us to do that.
We've grown conservatively,
and so we don't need a lot of investors
or extra cash to go
and to build new stores
or new businesses.
- [Narrator] Part of Cathy's values
are reflected in how employees are treated
and how they're expected
to treat customers.
- Thank you.
- My pleasure.
Y'all have a great day.
- [Narrator] Although you
won't see it in restaurants
where the employees are masked up,
Chick-fil-A has long asked employees
to greet customers warmly with a smile.
- Even if it's just in a
very small interaction,
you can share a lot by just the smile
the team member has with guests.
It's just a small little thing
that we can do that makes a difference.
- [Narrator] Occasionally,
Chick-fil-A's values
have attracted scrutiny,
especially when the
company's foundation donates
to conservative groups or causes.
- There's been some groups
perceived as anti-gay
and this has attracted attention
from progressive groups.
The company's foundation last year
has focused its charitable giving
on three different areas:
homelessness, hunger and education.
- I think the most important thing for us
being in the restaurant business
is that we serve everybody.
My grandfather, I love how he
talked about it with politics.
He would say, "I'm not
right wing or left wing,
I'm the whole chicken."
- When you go to headquarters in Atlanta,
there is this rock with
a quote from Truett
that is displayed prominently
that says what Chick-fil-A's
corporate purpose,
it says, "To Glorify God
by being a faithful steward of
all that is entrusted to us.
To have a positive influence on all
who come in contact with Chick-fil-A."
I do think that reflects
this very higher noble sense
of company self they have.
They believe they do more
than just serve chicken sandwiches.
- Thank you so much.
- My pleasure.
Have a nice one.
- Bye.
(lively music)